Project four is very different from
the first three projects that you have
worked on, in the sense you're not going
to be double-upping anything, right?
You are only going to be optimizing the
webpage that is already given to you.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, project four is where
you actually get to see
how each of the events in your webpage,
starting from your scripting
events to appending them and
rendering them on your website and
how much time it takes to load them and
how it's going to affect your whole
efficiency of your webpage as a whole.
>> So the experience of your users.
You know that feeling when
you scroll on a webpage and
it's just dragging or
it's kind of slow and lags?
It's a really unpleasant experience.
>> That's true.
>> And the best websites are those that
feel really smooth and are very usable.
So this is part of that usability.
And people's patience,
with high speed Internet, man,
we just expect things really quickly.
>> That's right.
>> And so,
optimization helps you make it look like
everything is much smoother and faster
just by being really efficient and
organized and methodical with the way
that we load our page and contents and
render everything in the proper order.
Also learn about caching.
>> For project four, it's important to
know there are kind of two major parts.
The first major part of project four
is getting a good PageSpeed score.
So, you have ngrok.
So, if you run your server
on your own computer,
you can then use ngrok to tunnel that.
So that then you'll get an actual URL,
which on the web you
can plug into sites.
Or you can also use GitHub
to make a bio page.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And plug that in if you don't want
to run a server on your own computer.
And there's lots of instructions and
good suggestions on PageSpeed Insights
to tell you how to optimize your page
and you can also apply a lot things
you've learned about minimizing the
critical rendering path in the course.
So through a combination of following
the suggestions on that page and
what you learned in the course,
you can increase your page score,
Insights score, to above 90 on both your
mobile and desktop version of your page.
The second part of the project Involves
really getting into the JavaScript.
I mean so once you've done all
the things that you learned about in
the course in order to
make your page run faster.
And sometimes it's actually your
JavaScript that slows you down and so
we've created some Cam's Pizzeria,
is a sort of fictitious webpage.
Somebody who wants to sell
these outlandish pizzas.
They're actually pretty funny
if you read the descriptions.
And you're supposed to
make that page faster.
And in that case it's
actually the JavaScript.
So take all your great JavaScripting
skills that you learned in OOJS and
apply them to that pizza webpage and
see if you can optimize it.
You're really looking at the Java code,
trying to speed it up.
We've given you,
just try it first yourself and
we've given you a lot of hints too.
If you look at the office hours and you
find a lot of the extra documentation
we've created, it should point
you in the right direction.
It's a good exercise to just
try it yourself first and
see what is inefficient about the code.
And then if you get stuck,
maybe look at more of the documentation
we've provided to sort
of get you all the way.
>> I think the next two parts of
the rubric is just on commons and
documentation.
Which is also a very
big part [CROSSTALK].
>> Very important,
not just within Udacity,
not just for your projects, but-
>> [CROSSTALK] Through
your career, yeah.
>> You communicate with people and
it's so
much easier when you add commons and
make your code readable.
So I think the next three
sections are the code quality.
So in this project, mostly you're just
editing code that's been given to you.
So make sure that the parts that
where you do edit is readable.
The indications are the same or
appropriate indications in the sense as
you go through it and
comments where you made changes.
And then they readme,
we want to know exactly how you
want us to work with your project.
>> That's right.
>> If you are hosting it on GitHub.io,
we want to know the website and
we want to know anything
else that you may have done.
If you use Grunt and Gulp,
let us know that you have used it and
just list out the optimizations
that you made.
>> That's true, yeah,
on some of the students,
actually it's not very necessary
to list out optimizations but
why we stress on it is because
the main .jsfile is so long.
It's huge and we are only going to check
specific areas that need optimization.
Which are the two fixes that Cameron
has already asked you guys to work on.
So, yes, definitely, we are going
to look through your main .js and
see if you made changes to it.
But it will help if we have a quick
bullet in the readme saying hey,
this is the part in this file that
I've got I mean part and change on.
So you can refer to it in main.js file,
but
you can also add bullets in your readme,
that would make things so
much easier for us and
make us grade your projects faster.
>> And don't ignore that readme
part because, I don't think anybody
over here likes to send submissions
bak for that one reason.
>> It's very difficult to see that
you've performed optimization,
it's great.
You've used these built tools,
it looks perfect and
we don't want to send back just
because you forget comments or readme.
Because yeah, it's a very important
part of your work as a programmer.
Any sort of field, any sort of
programming language that you use, yes,
do not forget to comment or
add a documentation of your work.
>> And you're not using GitHub.io
we do want to see instructions
on how you want us to host your website
over the Internet and check it.
So I guess-
>> I had students use LAN servers as
well in their project,
so they have had several
different methods to actually
host their webpages.
But do let us know you use.
>> What you're used to.